Jonathan Marsh ISO in tight mono makes the
save here's MCN with a WR shot save monbo
and the rebound turned away to off the Stick of
maraso amadio pass out of the reach of Carlson
he'll wave the icing gie back to get it now Harris
looking to spin away from DFI out in front Carlson
a puck bounce right to him for tangelo up ahead
Gallagher keeps it in didn't get a lot on that
it kicks to the blue line to ghouly now Pearson
and Martinez and deep Pearson to Gallagher save
hill with that right pan and he stopped the
rebound too Jonathan K Savage has [Music] it
gouie hitting new hook trying to flip the D and
a save hill burst a spade through the defense for
Alex no [Applause] hook Anderson hopped over his
stick barashev has Maro Maro has a step on M and
A save montedo it broke through him and then mat
kept it out of the net Canadians last year were
29th on both of their special teams PK's 20th
right now cter holding trying to feed it down
low Carlson back out top to cter again a wrist
shot score like that hit a Canadian on the way
to the net Paul Carter will take it the power play
goal and it's one nothing Vegas and whether this
a pass a shot it works good support as Carlson
gives him the option off this side right back
that's a shot that deflects off a Canadian
player up high the fronting shot there goes
off a stick up and over monteo perfectly into
the top part of the net tough break for the
Canadians kind of polar opposite goals for
Paul Conor from his second of the year the
dangle on G Philly to one that hit a couple
of players on Montreal found his way to the
back cter up ahead to Stone that'll give Hill
a chance to get to the bench cter steaming into
the offensive end dances through and he put
it off the post Stevenson out top feads it
towards Stone but might have been a little
too unselfish armia picks it off and clears
well Chandler Stevens just two shots in his
last four and Hill lost it and Monahan score
shorthanded now a gift goal for the Canadians
on a missplay by Aiden Hill and Shawn Monahan
short hand that his tied the game saying Chandler
Stevens in just two shots last four games this is
a perfect play right at the hashmark shoot the
puck trying a little too much looking for stone
it comes the other way and this is where Hill
comes out and he just fans on that puck right
to Monahan who just stops wide open net and
sha Monahan up to five goals on the season
[Applause] Coffield boui Harvey penard on the
wing pass into the middle went off of Carlson
and over the net and then H down low makes the
save on Harvey penard after Suzuki had jammed
it in front no shots for the Canadians on that
power play Let's see if the golden knights can
back to work here Carlson pulls up heed to
the colar shot sa rebound and that one off
the post I believe barers had the second chance
haga taken down I Anderson took the feto from
ha and then Hill somebody fell on him in front
Stevenson into the Zone backand pass TOS carry a
score second shot of the period for the
golden knights second goal of the season
for will Carri and to make it two to one but
it was bodies everywhere they keep possession
through the neutrals course Z find Stevenson
and look at this no look back pass carry does
a good job drives the far post kov does it
pick him up and a great feed from Chandler
Stevenson his carry with goals and backto
back games gives the Golden Heights the 2-1
lead on a delayed penalty on the Canadians will
carier gave the Golden Heights the lead Bruce
Cassidy thre his lines in the blender bit in
the second period how and aao and cter did not
see a lot of ice but I go with a steel trying
to tip it out mat couldn't play the bouncer
Carlson and Nel up by short hand forr joining
them Carlson to the net trying to center it
and it went right through the C and Mont and B
able to cover now Baron for Coffield trying to
with a shot pass looking for Harvey perard to
the top of the crease Baron Harvey Berard shot
deflected score Nick Suzuki tucks in the
game timeing goal with 418 to go running
around they spread it out side to side Puck
retrieval little play to the back over to the
side and they're looking for that shot pass in
front as Suzuki comes out from behind the goal
line as Harvey perard finds him and he puts it
in with a backand and the Canadians tie it at two
love to somehow find a way to get another one
well and that's it that's the opportunity they
have right now their golender giv them a chance
and see if they can here as they go to three on
three in overtime Jack eel one for two in his
career on penalty shots his first with Vegas
same monmo tried to go low glove and montmo
save the game for Montreal it's a play that
worked against the Kings and the shootout
mono stays with him and a big left pad save
and I don't sure eel got that he tried to go
go over the pad under the glove but Puck around
the wall Golden Heights have numbers stone
petrangelo stone to petrangelo what a safe
mono he robs petrangelo was even good an overt
well this after Hill made a save Stone to
petrangelo panelo again a chance bits it in front
and stone couldn't get the pass Suzuki the other
way with Stevenson back Monahan looking and he
missed the net M over the Blue Line forced into
the corner by Carlson who takes it away up ahead
to Stevenson they have time 10 seconds Theodore
and Stevenson Theodore lead pass Stevenson to
the neck lost it on the stick handle and may
have been bothered on the way by Monahan Carlson
going to run out of [Applause] time and he tucks
it into the back hand made the same move
the other night well it works it's tough
one for a goaler read watch how wide he comes
in change it slows up and then quickly to that
[Applause] backand Mar is one shootout goal this
year was a game decider for
Vegas pulls up [Applause]
scores the Canadians oh here it is there's
the stop just kind of slowly Glide little
move finds his area past the glove hul C field
0 for two this [Applause] season save hill
Theodore's also good in this spot five game
deciding shootout goals for him as we go to
the top of the four backand score off the
back bar and right back out for Shay theor
well seen that move he's got the forehand but
he loves the backand but it's about getting it
up it quickly elevates there's the move and
look how quick that is off his stick and up
under the bar golden knights can get out of
here with a win if Aiden Hill can deny Alex
new hook first shout tip of his career off
the crossbar and out and the Golden Knights
win they pull it out 32 in the shootout to
improve to 90 and one through their first 10